[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
look at that
[Applause]
happy tuesday everyone
so that was a big night last night right
huh
yeah we're doing an hour on abortion
i'm speaking of the met gala
at 37 grand per ticket and security to
keep us dirty folk at a distance
math photographers were still allowed in
to make sure the elites didn't get all
dressed up for nothing and what a
glorious spectacle of the world's
richest and most beautiful people
gallivanting like clydesdale horses and
drag starving themselves on cigarettes
and diet coke
the breakfast of supermodels
fun fact that's how mr ed's wife died
[Laughter]
so let's run through the conformity
there's katy perry
she seems to have lost her kooky style
and her mask when they asked her who she
was wearing she said hefty bag
there's kendall jenner take a look at
this she ditched her bra her mask
but also her eyebrows
talk about plucky
huh you go girl although i wonder where
her eyebrows ended up
[Applause]
talk about moving up in the world
she looks permanently surprised
like she accidentally sat on a poor
person
and then look at
cara delevingne
no shirt her torso soaked in gold paint
she better be careful or she might end
up in william devane safe
[Laughter]
she looks like a bowling trophy with
breasts
of course she had no mask either how
else would anyone recognize her
then there's hillary
in a long flowing gown
i gotta say that's quite a train and not
the kind bill likes
wait he's on fire
i'm referring to amtrak
thank you yes underrated
and without a mask you can look at her
smile although
it's probably gas
of course
the poor plebe handling the bottom part
of the skirt
is masked
so maybe she did have gas
but can you imagine if melania had a
black dude handling her gown the screams
of racism would be louder than the
dresses
but i often wonder what bill doesn't see
in her besides a soul
so there you go the perfect illustration
of how elites expect the rest to behave
it probably wasn't the unwashed masses
that coined the term unwashed masses
they enforce the rules for others but
not for them with or without the masks
we can see who they really are deep down
at events like this strutting around
like butter wouldn't melt in their lying
mouths who knew a couple hundred years
ago our ruling class would end up
emulating the very a-holes we threw off
our backs so we could be free in the
first place
the mass and unmasked master and servant
it's not about race or gender it's about
power the theme of the gala was gilded
glamour but it should have been the
victorian era contrasting excess with
serpitude and masks are definitely the
new whitehead caps worn by old maids
and it appears to have gone to a lot of
their heads
[Music]
oh my goodness our cup runneth over look
at this feast huh you know it's so nice
for kat to take us out to lunch but i
gotta say ever since she got back from
the white house correspondents dinner
she's been acting
different
what am i looking at here oh we only had
the one cheez-it no not that but where
are your masks you're not famous like i
am so you need to cover those
unrecognizable faces
i'm not even hungry
gotta go to the vomitorium to work up an
appetite plebes
take me there
good job if only she were acting
but if we learned anything from the
pandemic those in power could make you
lock down while being free as a mugger
in manhattan speaking of facing an
explosion in violent murderous crime
this is what new york's mayor eric adams
wears it's like liberace joined the
crips
pretty good
that's
on fire tonight yes that's a fashion
statement a tuxedo jacket that screams
and gun violence i mean he knows he's
the mayor right that's his job
rumor has it he bought it at a bill de
blasio yard sale
well this will stop crime for sure i'm
sure gangs thugs and criminals were all
tuning in to the met gala because they
have a deep interest in embroidery
but look it's easier to wear a shirt
with a slogan on it and actually write
and pass legislation that will help the
average joe you'd think they'd want
masks to hide the smug look on their
faces but if this works imagine how we
could solve other problems rather than
wielding hoses firemen could just wear
jackets that say
don't play with matches
the worst part the mayor's mask-less
while still forcing masked mandates on
kids it's true masks are no longer
required at sporting events or at galas
where the rich hang but brat still must
wear him at school he dropped his
vaccine mandate for athletes so now you
have a choice get the jab or play for
the knicks
the mayor also got a fresh pedicure
because nothing says you're for the
working class more than someone getting
paid seven bucks an hour kneeling at
your feet to remove your toe jam
look i get it
rich powerful people need to have fun
even when the people who voted for them
aren't
that's why every now and then dick
cheney shoots someone in the face
sky-high inflation
food shortages rampant crime we all need
a break from that including the very
people causing it
even nero took time off to fiddle
let's welcome tonight's yes
she's so chipper she eats wood and turns
it into sawdust outnumbered co-host
emily cabano
[Applause]
the only thing more magnetic than his
personality are his legs retired u.s
marine corps bomb technician and fox's
contributor
johnny joey jones
she's like a car's tail pipe
exhausting
fox's contributor cat tim
and when he raises the roof allstate has
to cover it my massive sidekick in the
nwa world television champion
tyrus
emily uh do you think it was a good idea
for the mayor to be there
i think he could have attended in a
better way than he did and here's what i
mean by that so this was a mayor who
came in who was a former police officer
right who sort of promised us or or
acknowledged the fact that all of these
issues have a lot of complex variables
right he wasn't this sloganeering
leftist coming in and gun violence right
he said i'm actually going to refund the
police i'm going to restore the plane
clothes unit and yes i'm also going to
try to find some some common sense
approaches to restore safety on the
street and also answer to like both ends
of the spectrum so for him to show up
with just that slogan on his back it
sort of reduced him to that
oversimplified i think uh progressive
left that he was supposed to not be a
part of it's sort of disappointing um
what would you wear if you went to the
gala something amazing
i'd wear a bra too by the way
and i also feel like hillary clinton no
offense but she looked just like mrs
potts from beauty and the beast which
isn't it's not i'm not trying to be mean
because i loved that that character but
right she looked she looked like mrs
potts well it was just possible at least
you didn't say the beast
no no
so that's a step up yeah you must have
that lockdown
visa is handsome i'm always compared to
that uh that uh weird looking the
candlestick guy that hits on everybody
yeah
lumiere
i don't know joey how are you
i'm good you know what i too would wear
a bra if i went to the met gala
i'm bench pressing about 400 now it's
probably necessary on top of that i also
got a pedicure to come here i was going
to so i couldn't find a i couldn't find
a belt sander and mineral spirits to get
it done so you know what feet what part
of the brain does this type of event
feed it's like the oscars are going away
but somehow people who consider
themselves edgy and wealthy and
beautiful and
and individualistic they still need to
come together they still need the
spotlight they still need to feel
important what is that you don't seem to
have that i don't i don't have that
that's why i wear my sleeves as tight as
high as hot as i can before i come on no
listen
i'm working tv man i got hubris like
everybody else but at the end of the day
people at home don't care about this i
don't think i don't need to get outraged
by it either yeah they literally just
don't care i mean when i saw hillary
clinton i thought about like the hunger
games have you seen those movies yes i
just was hoping that when she spun
around her dress would catch on fire
but it didn't happen that way
tyrus tyrus uh what do you make of the
mask the unmasked
dichotomy
it's
great job greg thank you
he tried to confuse me with dichotomy
i knew what it meant
i did know what it meant um
speaking of dichotomy uh
i was using another word i was thinking
more like
why
why go to work wear a mask i'm not
wearing a mask and these are the same
people that are virtue signaling and you
said it perfectly you're on fire tonight
oh thank you i particularly like the
[ __ ] thing that was pretty good
but
that aside here's where the mayor is
messing up see the brother obviously
he's envious he wants to be in the in
crowd
and that's not how you get to be in the
in crowd when you're mayor you have to
go back to
911
um
mayor i hate him saying his name now
because i think of the new borat mail
but giuliani when he was the mayor he
became famous on everybody's tv show
because of the work he did yeah because
he was in there if that mirror would i'm
not going to gala because i have work to
do in the streets people get behind that
it takes more than a sign on your back
it takes action and dirt under your
nails to get to the point where
everyone's like that's you become
america's mayor not because you made
appearances like that because you showed
up and you did the work putting a sign
in your back that everyone's confused of
talking about end gun violence what you
said is his job so he
he lost me
that night i know he's now just a guy
who wants to be famous
being a former policeman yeah he is a
former policeman because if he was still
a policeman he wouldn't have been there
he had been in the streets
excellent point yeah
what even is the met gala would you have
any interest in going not with me but
just going
thanks for clarifying
that was for hr
you never know
he asked me out on television hr does
not watch this show that's true if they
would if they were watching the show
would not exist
the met okay so the met gal is kind of
like new year's eve in times square to
me
where it's really hyped up but i don't
know if it's that fun and i don't know
how any of these people pee right
like all those dresses like they have to
come with a catheter there's no
[Laughter]
that's a great idea i got a whole bunch
if i did i would if i did i would
definitely have a catheter and a bra
which i never need but always wear
because it makes me feel grown up
i cat i see a marketing product for the
partier cat timp
catheter but it's spelled with a k oh
yes
that's a great idea i can already see
the infomercial it's you're coming
you're at a club and it's packed you're
going oh i can't go oh yeah and you're
and it's one of your friends and you go
have a cat what's that
cat i can't wait for my
i
can't wait for my branded line of
catheters to outsell all of your books
combined yes
all right before we go if you haven't
noticed we're in a brand new studio and
our audience is also back
and free tickets are now available go to
foxnews.com gutfeld for your tickets
right now isn't that exciting
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else